good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you're joining us
from welcome to simply learn we are
honored to have you join us today for
transformation to agile requirements for
business with your host Jeff Allen my
name is Richard and after the central be
mostly in the background helping jeff so
that everything goes smoothly and then
i'll come back in for the last 15 minute
question and answer period agile in
today's world and project management in
businesses this is one of the biggest
buzz words out there agile both for
having a successful business and for
having a successful career if you do not
know Jeff Allen jeff has over 19 years
experience in the industry as a
consultant in agile waterfall and
project management is the founder of
power payment get out of debt system
system lead instructor trainer and coach
4pm for over half a decade with
certification certifications and
everything from property project
management to xn all that is agile for
those who aren't familiar with this
former webinar I want to introduce you
to your dashboard if you could locate
your dashboard and then locate the
question module you might have to click
on the little red arrow of it auto
collapsed go ahead and that question
module type in hello or hi lets us know
that you're here you can hear me okay
and that you're excited to let Jess know
you're excited to be here we have I'm
not sure what the name is on there but
we have I want to say odd but a mesh ash
thank you for being here great to have
you give a specific a little richard
appreciate that one go ahead and let
this question module be your best friend
while we're here great place to is you
have quiz this we're going through the
presentation you have special questions
specific to your career path to the
business or company or in go ahead and
ask those questions at the end will take
15 minutes to try to get through as many
of those questions as we can we do have
an expert in here with the 19 years
experience so it's a great time you know
use I use that we have we have this
resource go
use it and we'll see what we can get to
and how many questions we can answer if
you hear something awesome brilliant
interesting insightful and you went to
share it in your social channels
whatever your social channels are if
you're on Facebook LinkedIn tweet you
can use the hashtag SL webinars that way
people can find it and you'll make them
wish they were here you didn't come here
to listen to me I am proud to introduce
Jeff Allen will be your host for
supporting innovation without with agile
or excess agile business go ahead and
sit back relax have a cup of coffee tea
or if it's evening where you are at
maybe a glass of wine and enjoy it's an
honor from your hand this over to Jeff
thank you and happy learning hello Jeff
and welcome to simply learn today I
Richard glad to be here excellent I'm
going to go ahead and mute myself and
give you full control okay thank you
welcome everybody glad that you're here
um I love agile and I'm fresh off of
doing a a Jelena ng4 webmd for simply
learned a couple of weeks ago and I was
reminded about a couple of things on
agile one is is just how brilliant and
effective it is and also just how
challenging it can be to actually
complete the transformation to agile I
am busy on some of my own projects and
I've even converted part of my basement
into a team room some of you might be
familiar with that and so not only am I
fresh off of spending some time out at
webmd but I've got a couple projects on
my own that I'm involved in right now
and so if you have any questions that
come up while we're going through this
go ahead and chat them in the question
box and we'll do our best to cover you
know any real-life questions that you
might have when we wrap things up here
so let's go ahead and get started with
some materials I've prepared first of
all we are going to just kind of
baseline our understanding on what
project management
is and then we'll talk about why an
organization would even consider
adopting a job and I'm not sure of
course what your perspective is you may
be one of the executives of the business
that's considering to making the change
to agile or maybe you are one of the key
people an organization that's running an
adoption effort but whatever it is we're
going to just make sure that we're
really clear why the time and cost
investment is worthwhile then we'll talk
a little about making a roadmap for a
transition and some of the complaints
you can expect and how to overcome some
of the resistance that can crop up when
we're involved in one of these
transformation journeys so when it comes
to project management I always just
figure project management is the science
of getting stuff done and everybody
needs to get stuff done whether we're at
work or whether we're at home or
whatever it is and so we're always
involved in some kind of effort to
manage what we're doing and get stuff
done now if we think about some more
formal formal projects we can go way
back in time we can think about the
pyramids in Egypt the Roman aqueducts
cathedrals in Europe the First
Transcontinental railway in America all
of these are examples of projects and
you know historically projects were
managed basically informally and it
wasn't until we get into the middle of
the 20th century that project management
begins to emerge as a profession before
that there were some tools that were
being used you know mostly ad-hoc things
something that is still around that
precedes the 1950s our Gantt charts and
there were other informal techniques and
tools but when we get to about 1950
that's when modern project management
really begins
and when it comes to just defining what
a project is it's a temporary endeavor
that results in something unique so
project management is about doing things
that are not part of the routine
day-to-day operations and so
organizations will undertake projects to
advance their strategic direction and it
could be internal projects at an
organization everything from changing
culture to handling customer orders in a
more efficient way customers are pardon
me companies undertake projects for
customers in order to make money that
you know creating something and selling
it is a project now when it comes to
software development constructing a
building expanding sales into a new
market and conducting research efforts
these are all examples of projects that
are underway all across the world right
now and you're probably involved in
something that kind of fits into one of
those broad categories but not all
projects are managed the same and there
have been two basic approaches to the
project management that have emerged one
which is the more traditional one is
called waterfall and one that is newer
that is it has its roots and software
development is agile and at a high level
waterfall is a plan driven approach that
favors identifying projects that have
clear requirements and then creating a
master plan on the front end and then
once executing begins measuring the
actual results against the plan in order
to determine the health of the project
the agile approach is different it is
for projects that are unclear the
requirements maybe are not or cannot be
defined well up front or it's expected
they will be changing frequently and so
the focus then is not on creating a
master plan and then managing your
budget and your schedule against the
plans but it's delivering value to the
customer in frequent short iterations so
two broad approaches the project
management and by the way team as I'm
out there in the world and it's likely
you might have observed this as well the
demarcation between waterfall and agile
is becoming a little bit more blurred
and I think that you know if you're a
practitioner you're going to want to
consider learning waterfall and agile at
some point now if you're a company
that's considering adopting agile um you
are going to be facing some issues and
it's not an easy transformation one of
these things where there's kind of a big
upfront um effort that's required but
once you get through that then the
benefits just start rolling in and agile
was originally come created because
there was a need for an alternative to
the documentation driven heavyweight
software development processes that are
done with the waterfall approach so
specifically the issues that were
challenging software development
projects that use the waterfall approach
was there was just too much
documentation um and it was very
expensive in terms of time and money to
react to change and those of us that
have been involved in software
development projects know that when
you're developing software there's
change all the time and then poor
quality and I'm sure some of us remember
you know going back to the early days of
software in the computer industry
software was pretty lame
and the documentation on how to use it
was not very good and and so you know
what was coming out of projects was not
serving the end user very well and so
agile emerged and there's a number of
methods that belong to the family of
agile but if we were to kind of
summarize the two approaches it would
look something like this when it comes
to planning on the waterfall side the
emphasis is on upfront planning and
identifying detailed requirements
upfront before starting design and
development on agile the emphasis is on
ongoing planning and so only high level
product backlog information is created
upfront and planning is deferred as long
as responsibly possible at the idea
being that we make the best decisions
when we have the greatest amount of
information so you defer planning
decisions as long as you can do so
responsibly when it comes to
communication and this would be among
team members as well as with other
stakeholders on in waterfall its formal
and it's structured in agile it's very
people oriented and it's informal but
it's constant when it comes to the
rituals or the ceremonies that are used
to actually do a project in waterfall
there's a high degree of that there's
formal team meetings there's project
reviews there's a lot of documentation
that statuses you know where the project
is what's been done you know what's
forecasted for the next bit of time in
agile it's much lower than that very
little project ceremony there there is
ceremony and it's important in agile but
that it's limited team meetings brief
project reviews documented status
reports with low details usually
informal when it comes to measuring
progress
in waterfall it's milestone driven and
we're creating artifacts to you know
share what has been accomplished in
agile it's it's different it's
delivering working software to the
customer and then when it comes to
change control and waterfall you can
change things obviously but it's a
formal process and usually there is some
kind of a formal change control board
that you know reviews proposed changes
and either formally rejects or approves
them um scope control becomes very
essential in order to make sure that the
project stays on budget and on schedule
in agile it's not like that it's limited
or nor formal or no formal change
control and then the scope is actually
expected to change and it expands and
contracts it can even change direction
but it's all based on the customer they
end users needs now if you're one of the
executives and I affectionately refer to
them as suits and I've been on teams and
I've been a suit and so I get both
perspectives on suits like budgets and
since like schedules and particularly
you know larger companies that are
publicly traded they make forecasts that
are embraced and shared at the wall
street level and if those kinds of
projections are missed it can have a
very negative impact on you know the
value of the stock and so what are the
suits want they want to know when
something's going to be done how much
it's going to cost and everything kind
of gets driven from the top down like
that and that creates one of the biggest
challenges when it comes to transforming
agile and no agile transformation effort
is ever going to end up being successful
unless the suits are part of it they
need to understand why
I agile is going to actually make it
better for them when it comes to budgets
and schedules and things like that so
one of the things that can help kind of
illustrate the value of agile and why
there might want to be you know an
effort to transform is this little chart
here this is a type of systems thinking
here where if you look at the lighter
colored things at the bottom left you
can see they're labeled simple and
complicated so simple that's meaning
when it comes to requirements and
technology you know everybody is pretty
much on the same place we know how we're
going to deliver whatever it is that
we're building with the project and if
it's not known up front it's easy to
know easily knowable complicated you
know it's a little bit more than that
not a simple project but the
requirements and the technology are
still knowable then in that green area
that's the sweet spot for agile and
we've labeled that complex meaning this
is where when it comes to both the
technology and the requirements not
fully knowable up front but we are
pretty clear on where we want to go you
know so there's some you know level of
reasonable predictability about it when
it comes to systems thinking it's always
wise to go to the other end of the
spectrum which we've labeled chaos and
that's where nothing's noble nor
predictable and therefore it's actually
not manageable so some order would have
to be brought to an effort that would be
otherwise chaotic before it could be
managed so you can see that you know if
you were building a building you would
not even dig the ground up to lay the
foundation until you knew what that
building was going to look like in the
requirements and you know everything has
to be identified up front it may not be
a simple project it could
be a large and complex building but the
requirements are the type of things that
get figured out on the front end but
software is not like that and the
trouble with software is if you try and
identify all of the requirements up
front you know how much testing is going
to be needed you know how many lines of
code are going to be required you just
don't know and the other thing is is
that it's very challenging to describe
what the end result of software
development is going to look like it's
not like a building where you can you
know mock-up a model I'm you can do some
of that and we do do some of that in
agile but usually when we get into some
of the modeling and the wire framing and
things like that um that's when you know
the custom rights you know start saying
well that's not really exactly what I
want and and so a more agile approach
becomes more effective so on agile which
really got its start in the late 1990s
has been the subject of a number of
different studies and one that I like to
bring to the attention of folks who
might be trying to decide whether or not
it's worthwhile to consider adopting
agile is a study that was done by the
Standish Group a few years ago and the
result of this study was that agile
succeeds three times more often than
waterfall I mean wrap your mind around
that three that three hundred percent
greater success rate than waterfall it's
not the waterfall is not valuable it is
but if you try and use the waterfall
approach for a software development
approach it's not going to be as
successful so a quote from the report
here that second bullet says the agile
process is the universal remedy for
software development project failure
we're applications developed through the
agile process have three times a success
rate of the traditional waterfall method
and a much lower percentage of time and
cost overruns now lest you think that
this is you know off the wall and not
grounded in reality the Standish Group
defined project success as projects that
were delivered on time on budget and on
scope and here we've got a graphic at
the bottom that actually shows the
results of their study and you can see
on the Left versus on the right the
difference in success and you can see
that even when it came down comes down
to projects that are challenged it goes
down so um you know if I were a suit and
we were continually being challenged by
budget overruns and delivering things
late I would at some point in time have
to say the way we're doing things is not
working and that's a great project
management question right because in
project management we always test and we
always measure and if something's
working well we do it again if it's not
working well we do something different
so you know as a suit I would have to
say you know what we need to figure out
if there is a better approach to running
our projects because um you know a
14-percent a success rate that's just
not going to work and you get that right
and so when you run a transformation to
agile one of the things that you've got
to do is create a road map on it is a
journey it's not an event on the suits
or the PMO or whatever it is can't just
say okay starting monday we're going to
do everything using agile and
not going to be doing waterfall anymore
it's not going to fly so there's an
acronym that we use you know those of us
that are involved in assisting
organizations in a journey and it's
called adapt here they're the focus is
on scrum scrum is the most popular agile
method there are many and all of them
agree on core concepts you know basic
things but you know they all have some
styles you know some emphasis on
different things and scrum is the single
most popular method in the family of
agile the second most popular one is XP
and between the two eighty percent of
all agile projects either use scrum and
or XP and scrum is by far the largest of
those two so adapt the first one is
awareness that the current process is
not working if what you're doing now is
working as project managers what would
we say there's no need to change if
we're a suit we would say there is no
need to change and that is foundational
to the question of whether or not you
would undertake a journey to do a job so
if things are not working you have to
have that awareness then the second is
the identification of what you're going
to do differently so there has to be a
desire to actually transition to agile
it will address those things that are
contributing to the process not working
then the second a is ability to succeed
with scrum so that looks like training
that looks like education I have done a
lot of trainings and many organizations
are so disparate in the lexicon that
they use
that sometimes the one most important
thing that training does is it gets
everybody using the same vocabulary so
that they're at least talking the same
language when one person says iteration
the other person knows okay I get what
an iteration is if a team is talking
about its velocity the suit said you
know can say oh okay I get what velocity
is and then of course there are
different types of rituals and
approaches that need to be learned and
embraced and practiced the next step
would be to promote scrum in order to
share the successes that are occurring
during the course of the adoption effort
sometimes an organization might start
with just a single project a pilot
project they might do it differently
than that but as the successes come
rolling in those things need to be
promoted around the organization so that
people begin to see okay although this
is kind of disruptive and things change
I got some wins coming in here so this
is worth it and then once that begins to
happen and begins to kind of permeate
the whole organization then you actually
finish the transfer and the transition
and you move everybody in the
organization into scrum or whatever
agile method it is that you're going to
be adopting so of course um you know
this is high level and you'd probably
want to have a more detailed road map
than just this but this is a good place
to start one of the questions that an
organization would ask once they've
determined to transition to agile would
be are we going to start small are we
going to do all in and there are
advantages and disadvantages
each if you look over on the left where
it says start small there's less risk
right you pick a project or a couple
projects um it allows you to kind of
cherry pick the team members that you
want to have on your first on agile or
scrum team and by doing that early
success is almost assured and you also
delay the burden in the challenge of
radical change because when you go from
waterfall to agile it's a big change um
but you could also do all in if you do
all in its going to be a lot faster it's
going to cost less money there's going
to be a whole lot of people that are
working on it instead of just a very few
and so there can be some cross learning
um if you're doing all in there's nae
says right here top down by n helps I
think that's kind of a week statement
actually now that I'm thinking about it
you have to have top down by in because
there's kind of a a gap that gets
created between the normal forecasts for
budgets and schedules that is necessary
when you do that transition and so the
the suits are going to feel a little bit
disconnected and uneasy so they've got
to be involved on the patterns that are
used to do it this is another area where
we would consider a number of things for
example once we start are we going to
make everything transparent to everybody
or are we going to run a project or a
couple projects sort of in stealth mode
so that we can control what we're
disclosing and when we're disclosing it
and there of course advantages and
disadvantages to both and you know the
culture of the organization is a big
driver in what patterns you use you know
to the right of that
um what about you know your technical
practices are you going to adopt a lot
of them all up front you know just go
for it or are you going to roll it out
in stages um as you go through the
transformation down at the bottom are
you going to split and see it or you're
going to grow and split so the split and
seed is where you use members from the
existing team to seed other teams to
help them in the transition or are you
going to grow and split so you grow an
agile team and you split it and then you
add team members to those smaller teams
and you grow and split and you grow and
split that probably at least in my
experience is more effective
particularly because a lot of waterfall
organizations have sido teams right you
have quality teams you have a business
analyst or product manager teams and
then you have you know engineers that
just do one kind of a thing in an agile
each team is cross-functional so growing
split seems to be the best that I've
seen but you know again it depends on
the culture if I was a suit and I was
being persuaded that you know we should
probably do this journey and transition
to agile I would want to make sure that
we did a pilot project you know instead
of you know deciding a on the front end
you know all in I want to see a project
and so I would rely on the project folks
to pick the right project and this chart
right here can be helpful in looking at
a number of considerations to identify
the right kind of project so if you look
at the upside down triangle that's
project size so you want to pick a
moderately sized project
if it's too large it might be too
complex the visibility might be too high
if it's too small it might seem
insignificant um if you look at the
business sponsorship one um you know if
I'm kind of the suit that's advocating
this and I've got some other suits you
know colleagues that are you know not so
sure I'm going to want to you know say
okay you know I'm in and if you're if
you're on the project side you're going
to want to have somebody like me that
you know is sponsoring that project and
you know and I might not be a hundred
percent on board as a suit but you know
I'm willing to authorize it and I want
it to be successful I'm not looking for
failure i'm looking for success when it
comes to duration you want it to be you
know a moderately um length of the
project if it's too long or too short
you know you're going to get critics on
both sides that are going to make it
harder for the transition and then of
course when it comes to importance you
know if you pick something that's
unimportant nobody cares what the
results are or if it's critical and it's
one of you first projects you know I all
eyes are on it and you know when the
criticality level is too high it can
create an environment where you know
little things that don't work out early
an agile project end up coloring folks
opinions going forward so if you're
going to do a pilot project you got to
select the right one get a sponsor from
the suit side of things and make sure
that you pick the right project now once
a transformation um journey begins
you're going to get complaints and the
complaints are going to come from you
know 360 degrees there's going to be
issues from customers is going to be
issues from the suits there's going to
be issues from testers and engineers
from HR from the PMO because everything
changes
um it changes for the good but the
environment has to change in order for
agile to work you know what we like to
say is agile starts as a mindset shift
it's not changing tools it's actually
changing your mindset so you know even
from team Amber's you know those that
are actually doing the work of a project
their complaints might be able on the
lines of we're spending all of our time
in meetings um what's funny is is that
it's really less time it just is more
ritualistic if you will you know those
of us that have been doing agile I know
about the daily standup that happens
every day of every work day with every
team member now it's only 15 minutes but
you have the daily standup the testers
you know these are folks that might say
well how come you know we have to have
everything tested even though we know
it's not going to ship until the end of
the release so maybe you know you have a
release that's been checked up in 20 say
you know eight or nine iterations the
testers are like why do I have to have
everything tested in the first iteration
it's not even going to be shipped for
two months and so and then the other
part of it too is testers actually
become part of the team and you know
they're not just kind of grouped
together testing the results from a
bunch of different engineering teams
star performers can kind of feel a
little bit dislodged in things because
we're in waterfall you know the focus is
much more on individual performance you
known somebody can become an expert and
become quite siloed in what they do when
you make a shift the agile it's all
about the team did the team deliver what
it was supposed to liver as opposed to
did you get your stuff done and so it's
actually the
team performance that is focused on and
is measured and not the individuals
within the team in fact those of us that
have been involved in agile enough we
know about one of the rituals which is
called a retrospective and one of the
main features of a retrospective is the
focus is only on what went well and what
did not go well and there is no looking
at individuals there's no blaming
there's no individual criticisms it's
all about the outcome that the team
experienced I'm old-school you know
those that have been doing waterfall for
a long time they're going to feel like
the level of documentation is not high
enough and they're going to feel like
wow you know what if it fails what if
there's a problem and they haven't yet
seen the vision of how the short
iterations lessen the need for
documentation and improve the
environment for actually getting things
that work done they won't see it that
way so they're going to complain you
know and even the customer can say you
know why do I have to spend so much time
with the team in agile the customer is
involved from the beginning of the
project to the end you know in waterfall
and those of us that you know of like
that our PMPs and stuff we know how we
go through the effort of collecting
requirements and creating the scope
statement and you know getting every key
stakeholder to sign off on it on that
level and once that's done the team then
shifts into executing and the
involvement of the key stakeholders and
the customer goes way down once the team
starts creating the wbs that's where the
expertise of the team comes in and the
customer isn't going to stand there you
know and show up every day and watch how
digging the you know the dirt out of the
way for the you know the parking garage
or the footings for the building that
I'm going to be involved there but in
agile they're going to be involved on a
daily basis when it comes to the
software that's being developed so the
guys do I have to spend so much time
so um you know this chart here just you
know gives you a bit idea of what kind
of complaints you can expect and those
of us that are smart will say okay you
know experience tells us that we can get
these kinds of complaints and so we
figure out on the front and how we're
going to address them we make that part
of our plan now you can actually have
some different levels of resistance so
this is different than complaints this
is the level of involvement that people
may have and we're going to use four
quadrants to go with this we're
borrowing this from Mike cone who's one
of the thought leaders in agile and
scrum specifically so we thank him for
this and so one of the things we're
going to consider is how folks resist
the transformation to or the transition
to agile it can be passive it can also
be active and we're also going to look
at why they resist um it could be
because they just like the way things
are they don't want to change they don't
see the need for it um and it could be
people actually dislike agile or scrum
for whatever reason a bad experience in
the past things they've heard from
others so in the bottom left quadrant
there we have what we called followers
and followers are those that are
basically just going to go along to get
along they like the status quo they
figure a July stuff ad and they're not
going to create any issues but they're
not really on board right they're just
going to passively resist expecting that
eventually things will return to normal
above that in the top left we've got the
diehards so these are those that are
going to actively resist because they
like the status quo um they think
waterfall is the best they do not see
the value of agile down at the bottom
right you have those that will resist
passively because
don't like agile or scrub now these are
folks though that they're there they're
part of it but they really they don't
want to be it's you know they didn't
have a choice so they're there then at
the top right you have the saboteurs so
these are those that don't like agile
and are going to actively resist they
don't want it they're going to actually
try and create failure so that things
can revert back to waterfall now there
are specific things that we can do to
manage the expectations and the results
when it comes to this these four kinds
of resistors when it comes to followers
one of the best things you can do is
involve them in the process so basically
what you want to do is you want to
convert them to agile so that they
actually see that oh you know what this
actually is better than waterfall and so
you'll involve them you'll praise them
for their correct behavior in likely
those will be your easiest converts on
your next easiest converts are going to
be those that resist passively because
they don't like scrum and so with these
folks you want to engage with them you
want to give them data you want to make
sure that their herd and then you know
hopefully they'll begin to see the
benefits of agile and say okay you know
I guess I kind of like agile or like
scrum the diehards um these are folks
where you probably have to create in
their own minds in their own reality a
dissatisfaction with the status quo
that's why some of the studies like that
Standish Group study that we looked at
can be helpful say you know yeah we're
getting stuff done waterfall is
structured it works i know you're
comfortable with it but look what
happens you know a three hundred percent
improvement
in success um and then you know you
might discover that one of the reasons
that diehards have an issue is because
they have some fears about the
transition what's it going to do to
their job what's it going to do to them
and so you address their fears on the
saboteurs you know that's kind of a
different group you got to deal with
these folks firmly because really can
you have team members that are actually
interested in your project feeling and
so these are the folks that i have to
say look I know you don't like agile I
know you're resisting this but the
decision has been made and either you
get on board and you start you know
being involved here and want success or
you're going to have to go because we
don't have room for you here that might
seem kind of harsh but you know if you
can't kind of deescalate things and turn
them into either a die-hard or a skeptic
they're probably going to have to go so
that's overcoming resistance and that
kind of brings me to the conclusion of
the formal presentation I have and so
with that can I just bounce it back to
you Richard it's certainly Jeff thank
you i'm always a good talk a little how
much i learn on these i wish i didn't
have so much stuff in the back that i
have to pay attention in addition to
that at this time we are going to step
into our question and answer period and
we have some great questions of some
very specific ones from people from i go
from IBM and some other ones on the
slides before i start those i do need to
start our polling which we do at the end
here while we do the question answers up
we do not have a pull up I don't know
why they didn't load the pole I don't
know if our if my Mohammed's in the back
so while I said a chat note back there
the pole let's go and start the question
and answer and I usually answer the
first question that comes up my seat
just came in from I don't know the name
on there exist or email can we get a
copy of the presentation yes we record
these presentations it does take up to
12 to 24 hours depending if there's any
problems with it because they look at
them and they make sure there's actually
recording there nothing's wrong on the
technical side to get a recording you go
to simply learn calm and click on the
support and just say hey it was at this
webinar can I get a copy of that and
they'll send you the links that you can
view that recording it and review it at
your own time let me go ahead and go
through here we have from I would say
the femoral llamar all my name is oh
here we go my name is a Wagner and I
worked for IBM and we are currently
going through a real company cultural
change around here which I think you
might have already addressed Jeff at
towards the end there you were talking
about the struggles of all the different
groups when you switch to agile sources
from earlier going through a real
company cultural change around here and
striving to transform into an agile
methodology driven company and there has
been a lot of discussion around the
colocation subject since we have been
for many years a company well known for
its work at home culture I would love to
hear your thoughts and insights
regarding the subject so he's asking
about the colocation subject I'm
concerned to agile framework what are
your thoughts on that Jeff yeah that's a
great question and it's something that
I've run into myself so for those of us
that let me contextualize the question a
little bit this way agile was created
for small projects small teams that are
co-located and when you get into agile
and you start learning about the
different techniques and the benefits
most of the discussion and literature
and training that's out there focuses on
the value of being
Oh located and that's where the roots
are and there is value in being
co-located what is different now than
was the case you know 20 years ago is
technology and you can do agile with
virtual teams but you have to leverage
technology now I had a real live
situation this was just a few years back
and I got a buddy who um knows that I do
project training and he said have got a
project I I did a deal with a software
development company they quoted me
twelve thousand dollars to put up a
website said it would take a maybe 90
days he says it's been a year and a half
and not only is the twelve thousand
dollars done I've paid twice that I owe
him some more money he says how about
you quick training and you come and do
and here's the thing um my buddy's
office was in Utah the owner of the
company that was doing the software
development was also in the States and
all of the engineers were in Costa Rica
and so it was a virtual environment and
when i first got involved they actually
said that they were doing agile and when
I kind of got into it I thought you know
this really doesn't look very agile to
me and so one of the first things I did
is I actually worked with everybody you
know from the owner of the company to
focus on you know the customer side of
things as well as the engineers and what
we did is we implemented the use of some
tools one of the tools we used was
Google Hangouts and we didn't do this
every day but frequently um I would just
have everybody join a google hangout
session camera on microphone on and we
all just work and you know I'd be in my
office here in Utah and I'd hear you
know the engineers
down in their rooms in Costa Rica
talking about stuff and then every now
and then one would say hey Jeff I got a
question on this user story I'm working
on or I would say hey Julio can you tell
me where you are on this particular user
story you know might have a requirement
issue on my end and so but I would also
hear them take phone calls and they
would hear me talk to other folks but it
was like we were in the same room so we
leverage technology and then we used a
software program called version one to
create a virtual team room and there are
a lot out there version 1 ended up being
probably more than we really needed but
there's JIRA there's Trello there's
others that we leveraged and the idea
then to kind of circle back to your
question Wagner is can you do colocation
and be effective with agile and the
answer is yes and what you do is you
still keep the small team
cross-functional team environment but
you then leverage technology to create a
virtual team room and uh and then that
connectivity kind of a virtual teen
space where everybody's connected
throughout the day if you have time zone
issues you might have to include a
little bit more formal rituals you know
specific times to review things maybe a
little bit more documentation than you
normally would but usually that can be
accomplished with the software that
you're using whether it's version 1 or 0
or something like that so a Vagner can I
just double check that answer the
question for you well enough yes thank
you okay thank you very much on I might
you know just occurred to me that you
know based on some of the trainings I've
been sometimes it's very helpful to have
either somebody internally that gets
designated as sort of a code
or an evangelist for it or even better
sometimes is you know a temporary you
know consultant arrangement where
somebody comes in with some authority
that can kind of disrupt things a little
bit in order to you know get folks to
kind of align with the program if you
will and be less resistant to it okay
Richard is there another question oh we
got lots of great questions coming in
let's go a little bit more on general
terms and I know for myself one of the
things I we all learn differently so I
always struggle with definitions I get
all the complex part of it and then I
just really can't remember what a word
stands for so on that note can you give
a concise definition of scrum along with
who can be scrum master what is the role
of scrum master talk a little bit about
this from side of things I can so scrum
is actually just a term that has to do
with rugby so it's not an acronym so
scrum is just a made-up term for a type
of agile project management so it's a
method and in scrum there are three
roles one role is the scrum master
another role is the product owner in the
other role is the development team the
scrum master is an individual the
product owner is an individual the
development team is a group of
cross-functional engineers testers
whatever's needed that is usually six
plus or minus three inside the the best
thinking on it right now is you never go
larger than nine on a development team
and together those three roles create or
are called the scrum team so you have
the scrum team and then you have the
development team on the product owners
job responsibility is the scope of the
project the product owner is the
customer representative or the customer
voice for the project when you're using
scrum
and is a responsible for identifying the
functional requirements for the project
the development team would address non
functional requirements uh might have to
do a security and scaling and other
things like that that might be necessary
that the product owner from the
customers point of view might not even
really be aware of you know architecture
things and things like that work that
needs to be done that our foundational
or predecessors to you know functional
requirements being able to be completed
the product owner also determines the
priority of things based on the
customers view of value and the product
owner has to make the tough decisions if
the development team says you know in
our next two weeks print on we can do
three of these five user stories you
want done we can't do well five it's not
possible the product owner might not
like that but the product owner
ultimately has to make the hard decision
as okay these are the three we're going
to do on the development teams
responsibility is to actually create the
working software which includes
everything from design to coding to
testing to demonstrating it the scrum
masters job is a servant leader position
who facilitates the success of both the
product owner and the development team
so a great scrum master is going to work
with the product owner and do with
things like return on investment and
payback period and sequencing and
creating the greatest amount of value
for the customer as quickly as possible
the scrum master also works with the
team and is primarily responsible for
removing impediments on the scrum master
wants the engineers the testers
whoever's on the development team to be
working and working as fast and
effectively as they can and while it
might seem a little bit goofy you know
if an overflowing trash can is impeding
the work of the team the
I master empties the trash now it's more
practical than that in the real world
you know it might be making sure
equipment is working maybe getting
software maybe some training and things
like that but the idea is the scrum
master facilitates their success by
removing impediments and then the scrum
master is also the advocate if you will
for sprung and works with trains guides
coaches mentors both the product owner
and the development team members in
actually how to do scrum did that get
your question answered or did I miss
anything we actually like three
different people ask questions on the
scrum so I don't know which one you're
addressing is we had a shish we had Joe
we had not Joe it was Ramesh and yes we
got yes I'm one of those I have a
another question that came in as far as
both at the level of like setting up a
company who is moving into agile and for
individual careers what kind of
certification or training would you
suggest so if we had I know we had
somebody from IBM but let's say you have
a group in a company you know like 30
people in the company and they have four
projects going on they're dividing it up
what kind of certification or a path
would be really good get that company
jumping in the right direction for using
the agile environment for their
development what kind of certifications
yeah that's a great question you know
when it comes to certifications it's
always a bit of a conundrum because
they're all based on passing
standardized tests and most people have
ever taken standardized tests say well
those they're just stupid they really
don't measure or predict somebody's you
know capability and you know viability
in the real world but the thing of it is
is that if you want to get ahead
gotta get certified there's just no
other way around it it may not be ideal
but it's the best that we have and so
there are really two agile
certifications that I think ought to be
at the top of someone's list and you
know maybe you don't do both but it
wouldn't be bad to do both so one is
agile scrum master on this is an egg's
in certification it's not us based on
and its focus is on scrum but it does
introduce you to some of the other
methodologies but it has two modules
that our particular interest one is how
to scale agile so how do you have
multiple agile teams working on a much
larger project and then another module
and that training and is covered by the
certification is enterprise or but not
that's scaling but the transformation
the actual journey what do you do when
it comes to actually having your
organization go through a transition so
the advantages of that certification are
that it focuses on I shouldn't say
focuses but it has questions in testing
on scaling agile as well as agile
transformations another one worth
considering is pmi-acp PMI is us-based
PMI is huge AC P stands for agile
certified practitioner so it's agnostic
when it comes to a scrum or XP or others
some of its value where it is really
good is understanding and testing on
agile as an approach not much about
transitions not much about scaling but
more about how to do agile on regardless
of whether you're doing scrum or XP or
crystal or Kanban or whatever
um and some organizations weigh in on
that you know some like PMI because
they're so big eggs in has been around
for a long time but they're not as well
known at least if not in the states as
PMI is so i have i actually have both of
those so i'm speaking from my own
personal experience I like having both
actually so you know maybe you pick one
and then you do the other one but those
are the two that I think are worth
looking at mmm excellent let's go
there's one there's another question on
from an a the knee up i'm saying that
right he currently is working in manual
testing with a main friend is probably
along the same lines as what you're just
talking about which certification and
agile if he was coming from mainframe
doing manual testing with mainframes to
move his career up into a more project
management in moving forward out of the
mainframe i'm guessing that's what he's
asking I hope I got that right in there
right okay yeah and they I think my
answer would basically be the same
either pmi-acp or ASM you know there are
some certifications out there offered by
organizations that are just scrum
related and there's value in those the
the challenge that I see with those is
that they're so narrowly focused and
some of the testing on those is pretty
lightweight but if you really wanted to
get into agile and have some versatility
and be able to offer broader value to
employers or just you know have it
yourself ACP or asn would be what I
would say mmm excellent excellent i
should be looking into some of that
myself from my background if we can go
back as i have some more specific to the
content we have a question on the ona
you're very welcome thank you for noted
that we appreciate your question we have
a question on nine percent fell on the
pie chart of edge
well I guess it is like towards the
first quarter of your talk can you see
we see neighbors have fail in the pie
chart of agile what could be the reason
for that fail I guess we look for
reasons why a gel fails in a project
there can be a number of reasons when
agile project would fail but usually
it's because you're trying to do agile
and you're not really buying into it so
one of the things that I see common out
there is people will say we're doing
agile and they're really not and so they
still are vexed by the issues of going
over budget and going longer than they
were you know supposed to based on some
kind of you know imposed budget or
schedule so in agile your budget and
your schedule emerges throughout the
course of the project it happens early
in the project you know as the team
starts you know producing in the
velocity becomes known and then it can
become very accurate in predicting where
it's going another problem you know to
not just actually fully implementing and
doing agile is that the customer is not
engaged properly you cannot do agile if
the customer is not giving regular
feedback if a team decides to do sprints
or iterations that go too long you know
three weeks or four weeks I'm having a
bit you'd even do any longer than that
you're not getting the feedback from the
customer that you need and so the
customer I would say I'm not accepting
this this isn't what I want and that can
be a failure there are other reasons you
know it could be just you know money
running out you know some of the more
practical things the the customer
actually just saying I don't want to do
this anymore trying to think things that
I've run into you know sponsorship ends
the team minute the team doesn't have
this
skills that it needs but you know those
things kind of things get addressed it's
usually that agile isn't really being
done the way it should be excellent and
just a quick note we are like one more
question I think we're going to take
before we close the session if you have
some questions that come up after this
session or you want to know more about
simply learn and their get certified
program to get you certified in the
different agile aspects and different
certifications available you can
definitely visit simply learn com we
have usually a live support right there
that comes up and then you can also
click on the community and there's an
open forum in there we can also ask
additional questions and our experts do
go in there and look at those questions
regularly so you have both a community
forum so it is like I said open to
anybody to answer and they also and the
experts coming in who do know their
business as far as the different
certifications and options that are
available let me go ahead and the CBM
here we go can you speak to the process
of converting high-level business
requirements into epics and ultimately
stories as from a Joe thank you Joe so
process is converting high-level
business requirements into epics and
ultimately stories and you might want to
talk about exactly what an epic isn't a
story is yeah so what you're really
talking about is what we cover in some
of our trainings that we call the the
planning onion which you know you start
at the broadest level which is strategic
and then you get down to portfolios and
then to products and then two releases
in them down to Sprint's so epics are
groups of users stories that are grouped
together to simplify planning but epics
eventually are going to have to be
disaggregated into smaller user stories
that can be completed in single sprints
so there's sort of a hierarchy so if you
start with a product road map that is
divided in two maybe three or four
different versions or incarnations you
would use releases to support the
product roadmap so like release one
might be version one you know release
two might result in version 2 for
example releases are supported by actual
Sprint's or iterations so a release
might be disaggregated or broken down
into you know 15 or 20 Sprint's when at
the end of those 20 Sprint's the
releases rayon version 1 can be taken
life um and then each sprint is broken
down into tasks and our run usually in
durations of two to four weeks so did
that help yes Joe came back I don't know
if you can see that on your screen okay
I get over that question is a great
question in breaking that down and then
we have one last question will sneak in
here see about CSM I'm not even sure
with CSM but i'm not a project lead
manager i do other work what CSM is and
what that isn't like with the part that
plays in the industry you familiar with
CSM i am that stands for certified scrum
master on it is a certification offered
by i believe it's the scrum alliance and
it's sort of a quick training where you
get into scrum deeply and then take a
test right after it's an open book test
it's popular because it's inexpensive
and it's quick and you know if you're
breathing
can probably pass the test the problem
is is that it's pretty lightweight I
don't want to cast aspersions there but
I know that it's pretty easy to get a
CSM and it doesn't get deeply into um
agile as a family of methods like other
certifications do so it's very narrowly
focused and relatively lightweight so is
there value and it sure there's value in
it a good place to start if you're you
know you're going to dabble or your
company requires it in a better place to
go would be like a sm a july master
because it's broader it's a bit harder
of a test but you know the test is
harder than you know it's more
meaningful in the world hmm excellent
excellent so on that note i'm going to
go ahead and we're going to bring the
section too close thank you Joe for the
comment on the I guess the onion our
acronym you guys were talking earlier
with Joe so we go ahead and bring this
to a close because we have gone over a
little bit here which is fine and I want
to thank everybody for being here today
we definitely appreciate your taking the
time out of your day to come listen to
our webinars again simply learn calm or
hashtag SL webinars if you have an odor
you want to share something you learned
in the webinar today on your social
media and I went thank you Jeff for
being here thank you for taking your
time out today to share your knowledge
and I certainly learned a few things
today and I wasn't even paying close
attention to like I said ever the things
I do I have been here fun stuff and team
can I just say good luck to all of you I
wish you the best excellent and happy
learning to everybody and we look
forward to seeing some of you in our
classrooms
you